there is an awakening everywhere and
those 100-plus nights have changed the
social fabric of America what has stayed
the same has been the justification of
killing black bodies and that has not
only been exhibited in st. Louis area
but throughout the nation
Oh
people I believe in general are way more
aware of their surroundings and what's
going on with them and justices in their
communities and people want to be
involved everything now is moving in the
right direction but what we got to do is
just keep that pressure on we can't
think now everything is okay that's the
mentality you don't want but if we
hadn't been doing what we were doing
they when the guy rid of the chief that
now Ferguson would never be the same as
long as we keep pressure on it but I
believe it's going in the right
direction if you look at the fact that
the African Americans that are on the
City Council for the first time ever
comprise half of the City Council that
is an improvement from where we were we
have the first african-american city
manager first african-american interim
city police chief I watched those
individual especially among our young
people become more conscious of what
they should be doing as a people and a
community what hasn't changed i believe
is still the same thing is a police
brutality against unarmed individuals
most of us making the difference is not
so much as media it's just even people
are looking at their own rights with
technology with the phones they're able
to film what's going on with themselves
what we haven't seen accomplished really
is the systemic change that we seek for
it we can seem to be shot down in the
street without any kind of
accountability on behalf of those who
are supposed to be for our protectors
the police need training so that they
would know that we are human beings and
that they cannot continue to treat us
with the mentality that exists in their
mind
so it has to be uprooted in order for
there to be a change
you are the change that you want to see
the show it it doesn't necessarily give
you a straight answer of how to fix it
because there's no true way to fix